あああああんあざーーん the doctor 始めた皆さんはネズミ捕りという
ものをご存じだろうか
まあ名前本当にネズミを捕まえる装置がんだがコレですねネズミ捕りしっかり商標登録
もされております結構原始的な造りで以下やってみますね
ねずみ取るとかざっとして死んじゃうんだろうナマってこう集まって本当に待ってや
ばいばーい
威力が強いスはとりあえず普通に何か見せたら頭指取れるかなちょっときます
こうやって来ですねうはコアもうやばいこれじゃあ設置完了してて
秒いってネズミをおびき寄せるためにチーズこいつ横はセーフティを解除しますでここ
にネズミが肥えてきたら
[音楽]
まあ今はなかっ
スコアバー
あってこれこれ全然で猛暑は命待って普通に別には5人余り
カーヴィーボディ
こういった1月ますネズミが来るとしましょう
音ズレ声でワイワイできたら
a で完全に創業とされているもうこうやってバツ2でてネズミを退治できるわけです
ね
栗見て今回そんなネズミ捕りなんだが新たクシドクターはじめ長年の研究を重ねて重ね
て重ねて重ねて重ねて本ネズミ捕りを多くしてみました
[音楽]
僕がやったわけじゃないんですけどどうぞ
はい
お願いしまーす最初はそれでネズミ捕り果たせる長谷川てぃあ
斎藤ロス ki ドクター g 思ったんですけど
ねずみお金ない敬愛するできるんでパコられ巨大化すると平気になるんじゃないかなと
思います言っていいですか
完全に等しいますねえって早速もう下に
ケツしてるということで長はそんな巨大化してネズミ捕りでず1件していきたいと思い
ますぜひ高
[音楽]
あげるわけですウズ額の20倍の千巨大ネズミ捕りでございます
ああああああ
これ普通のサイズなんですけど比較しても病でも思ったですよもう触ってみてもいいか
豆腐と思います
まずそこらへんの力のかここまでもない力
ちょっとや新設定バージョンコリアンねぇこれをタッチのでミーってこれでのこれで
ロングして
はずとは
ポンポンあのーセンター honda 一人でやりたかったんですけどちょっと甘いに
引き上げているという猫
ついてくださることになりましたのではい安全に取り扱っていきたいと思いますはい
です
じゃあ親父ますはいじゃあ今歳くらい恋
ね
うわぁを都度対応早くて生活安全力を確認してみたい
アン北京ダンボール作中だったら
今は妻を願うさあ
ねーっ
ああああああ
[音楽]
もう生まれ
殺人兵器だふざけ強度なんですねこの巨大ネズミてるを使っていろんなものをぶち壊し
て行きたいと思います新聞医療検測気になるところですね
が最初は後かられてみたいと思いますじゃあ
[音楽]
あああああああああああ
おえーいえーい
4 a
悲鳴に半分だけどそれでビンゴは反乱になっちゃったんですけどあの真っ二つになった
わけではなくもう版が粉々になってしまいましたありがとうございましたはい次はです
ねこちら
ニンジンでございます音がりんごスイブ服でてこんなんでスキャンダル意味だろ
ニンジン結構仲コツなんでどういうリアクションがミロスと分からない
me
くれましたけどありがとうございました
ん
[音楽]
一緒ですか
範囲で8月で一月はこちらパイナップルでございますサインアップ硬いんですよね
やっぱり
この周りの壁がそれをいかにこの巨大ネズミてくださいできるかが見どころですね
いきましょううーん
ええええええええええええ
me
はぁ
おおおッ
[音楽]
9 f 得ず5位
うわっっ
パイナップルアレルギーだと思う入っただけで次はこちらストロングゼロでございます
たくさん買っちゃったんでちょっと1個ぐらい絶景に使っていくのトップ使わせて
いただきます
選んだ道ですからたわけですね
ee
[音楽]
ブーブーお願いしまーす
はいん
tan
wh
[音楽]
今年はであります
小磯
[音楽]
bl
ぷっ